مساء الفل ليه ما بنلتزمش بالدايت علماء
الاقتصاد السلوكي اكتشفوا ان سبب عدم
التزامنا بحاجات المفروض نعملها علشان
نحسن حياتنا سواء الصحيه او الماليه هي
وقوعنا في فخد حيز ادراكي بيسموه الحسم
المغالي او هايبر بولد فكره التحيز ده هو
اننا كبشر عندنا ميل شديد للافعال
والاشياء اللي لها مكافات فوريه حتى لو
كانت على المدى الطويل مش في مصلحتنا فكره
الالتزام بنظام غذائي صحي فكره عظيمه جدا
وفي مصلحتنا ولكن مشكلتها هي انها مالهاش
مكافاه فوريه مكافاتها بتتحقق على المدى
الطويل وبالتالي بتعتبر مكافاه مؤجله
علشان كده الناس ممكن تضرب الدايت بالجزمه
لو اتحط قدامها اكل حلو علشان الاكل في
اللحظه دي هو مكافاه فوريه واكيد فبنختاره
على حساب المكافئه المؤجله والمحتمله اللي
هنجنيها من الالتزام بالدايت على المدى
الطويل في صوره صحه افضل وجسم رشيق ما
تنسوش تشتركوا في قناه المخ بالاقتصاد على
اليوتيوب عشان تتابعوا حل